good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you come out so you can have a positive
impact on yourself on your family your
community and the world so to help you
on your journey today's message is work
smart over to you Jack Ma who works
harder the people at eBay are the people
of Alibaba it's sometimes you have not
only have to work how you have to work
smart mm-hmm so would you say you work
smarter than my BAE I'd have to say yes
right well so far yeah so so far okay
because because I think you know we are
pretty lucky people and the people see
you yeah you work very hard chew in this
world that so many people work very hard
but they're not that I told my team when
we I'd pill I asked a lot of people
sitting there I say you know all of the
you guys motovlog I millionaires and so
rich but 15 years ago who are we
it's so difficult for us to high people
15 years ago people who are not that bad
I said people can walk still walk on
three we hide them because nobody
believed internet nobody believed
internet and they join a company those
people who believe they're smart they
were had hunted by two the other company
said as their own company those people
know nobody go to hell hunting them this
state today the successful very rupee
reasons we exist will persist we never
give up we believe the dreams together
if you want to succeed as an
entrepreneur you need to work both hard
and smart you need both everybody who's
had massive success did both forget
about trying to work a 4-hour workweek
forget about passive income yes you can
make a little bit yes there might be
supplemental income to help you along
your journey but if you want to do
something impactful you want to have a a
big change in the world you want to
really be somebody special and have
a ripple effect out from you you gotta
do both you got to work really hard look
at whoever your heroes are whether it is
that you look up to they didn't get
there by having things handed to them
and they didn't get there by trying to
create passive income or work four hours
a week and I love the four hour work
week book there's a lot of principles
you can use in there except the fact
that when you are committed to something
and you love it you got to go all-in on
it
stop being lazy lazy people don't change
the world lazy people don't have a huge
impact I want you to have a huge impact
and so hard work is just your ticket in
hard work alone is not the answer
there's lots of people who work really
hard and they never rise up they never
reach their potential right you can work
really really really hard as a cashier
but if you're not thinking on a bigger
scale and you're not working smart as
well then you'll just continue to work
really really hard as a cashier and make
whatever a cashier makes and that's
where you stay hard work does not
guarantee your success but there is no
success without hard work period it
doesn't exist
show me somebody who you really look up
to and really respect who hasn't put in
a ton of effort hard work and smart work
to make it happen and so I think if you
are just looking for shortcuts if you're
just looking for ways to make that
passive income or ways to work four
hours a week and then spend the rest of
timeline on the beach you're being lazy
and you haven't really tapped into the
thing that you love doing because I can
tell you you get tired of lying on the
beach you may not agree because your
life sucks right now because your work
sucks right now because you're just
trying to escape but people want to do
things that have meaning after you've
escaped your life and you spent a year
on the beach you're gonna get tired
you're gonna get bored you want to do
something that fills you up we want to
contribute human beings want to
contribute we want to feel like the work
that we're doing matters and we'd like
to work we'd like to feel like the
activities that we're filling up our day
with means something that somebody else
so you gotta find that and when you do
you don't want to just work four hours a
week it feels you up you want to do it a
lot it doesn't mean you're spending two
hundred four hours a day doing it you
find the balance for you but when you
find the work that you love you want to
go all in on it you were going to keep
going because it fills up your soul so
you've got to work hard and you've got
to work smart it's the only way to
succeed as an entrepreneur
so the question bait today is I'm
curious who is somebody that you look up
to who has achieved a lot and worked
hard and work smart
give me some role models I'd love to
know who your personal heroes are
Sheridan counts below looking forward to
hearing what you have to say I also want
to give a quick charter to Beth Lesley
Beth thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
you know what I noticed the Marion I
want your opinion sure I I've noticed
that every idea that I've had whether is
a drum kit or the podcast or whatever it
was past the auks good they're all
things that I felt like would end up
being really fun to do and and so my
kind of philosophy I'm adopting now is
like if it's fun fun it's probably you
know why that happens it's a it's a
bigger macro situation because it's fun
you're willing to work your face off and
working your face off is actually the
gateway it's not the fun the fun is the
doorway that gets you to put in the work
that gets you the results because d-roc
loves filming like the 24/7 nature of
what he does is you know is what so many
kids want to film into this but they
don't want to it's not fun enough for
them you have to love it the cost of
entry now is you see you understand you
have to love like for me building brands
whether it's my own brand brands for
other people other things the why it's
so the only thing I give it about that
I'm willing to put in the 19 that it
takes because the problem is now with
the internet like we were just saying
being the middleman and everybody can
play there is some kid in Kansas City
who's gonna put in the 19 to take mice
now what's amazing is though
the biggest thing I didn't know is
that's some fun but there's so much that
all those little that are gonna put in
the nineteen are gonna get theirs too
and that makes me happy yeah so I would
say funs a great gateway to fun is the
precursor to ridiculous amount of work
which then gets you there if the message
is true if we can really have our wishes
if dreams do come true and there
certainly isn't they get up every day
and go do something they don't enjoy
with people they don't respect for money
that's not sufficient what would be
their first step toward going from where
they are to where they want to be well
if they have the opportunity is to step
back and say okay if I had a blank sheet
of paper what would I be doing each day
and don't say nothing because that's the
hardest job in the world
figure out what you have passion for and
being willing to apply the discipline to
achieve that passion when we go to a
sporting match for example we see the
end result of people many people who
have done a lot of sweat a lot of
training a lot of passion to achieve
their abilities but we don't see all the
work that goes behind the scenes so if
you're not prepared to do the grunt work
the scut work the discipline and that's
why it's often said people who have
worked hard to in terms of a discipline
way end up being freer than those who
don't have to do anything because then
they can't do anything true most things
in life that are worthwhile you got to
work at you got to work at you get out
what you put in as simple as that that's
a kind of a universal law so yeah it's
not pick up the guitar and go haha which
I've done you know in front of the
mirror Lots you know hey I'm really good
and you got to have that attitude too
but it does take work it does take you
know some dedication you know but if you
love doing it it's not as hard as is it
could be if you're you know you're doing
something that's not it you're not as
interested in if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details